I'm sure I'm only cracked out and like
anyway are we filming know how many much
grace helbig don't know now you know
your life is different now guess what
we're back into making videos I said
we're back in Jamaican do you know that
little mix video where she's all she has
to do an impression of an accent and she
picks Jamaican and she goes like we're
back in Jamaican mom and that's the new
a separate videos I've had some time off
to really consider what my friend is now
and it's that mom and I have this fun
idea because I took a little distance
away from YouTube Tyler had reached out
when I had tweeted about wanting to make
videos again and I thought this is the
perfect kind of opportunity to give back
into making videos because Tyler was the
first person I ever quote collaborated
with on YouTube he was still in college
I was it was like in the time of YouTube
when he would send clips to each other
but you hadn't met yet you live in
Michigan I was in New York there were no
youtubers in New York at the time I came
up with like a dumbass yet I don't
remember what it was and I remember
emailing or messaging you and then you
were so like gracious and nice and kind
and responded like immediately if I gave
you like a script to read I think sent
me clips and then I edit it together I
stay away from doing these types of like
react to old video videos because they
give me so much cringing I'm like ready
to hate myself I thought we should go
back and watch some of the first
collaborations that we did together this
is like seven or eight years ago and I
already have a stomach full of anxiety
also because I chug coffee for you Roger
Bacon my man okay are you ready yeah I
might have to turn it off if it gets too
much but that's what controllers she's
going
not this oh my god oh my god at my myrn
okay so y'all know this is the script
she gave his actual candid responses to
any of this hey grace no unfortunate
okay acting up EMS was that the only
question you had planned yes that sounds
so you I guess the business well I mean
we could talk about I remember this now
I hate me is that it was that oh man the
golden years of YouTube I really thought
I was a comedic genius when I wrote this
sketch
I probably thought I deserved at least
the Daytime Emmy okay so the next one
was years later I had moved to Los
Angeles Sam you came over to the cabin I
was living in this is when I sideswiped
I never said I was good at anything in
my life and then we you know move past
that and then made this video what video
[Applause]
no it's a my tie my tie I was coming
into this one hot yeah that's wrong
yeah that's a memory and I'd tag team
you were great
that's how you know I don't think this
is really good luck thank you have a
secretly gone throw it what is my hair
YouTube Oh T P should be me continuously
confused by every Clapham ever anyway
what am I ever doing I'm I look like a
fetus fashion I also think this was five
or six years ago okay so I'm really
curious to see what youtubers are
talking about this is broad daylight
today and I am black and you know maybe
just off camera judging us okay
I was so nervous for this day I said
Kingsley oh I feel like they're just
like the top of the tier and I would
love to watch that's good that was smart
of me missing jokes in that picture of
Hannah oh my god I went with a website
that's very related xtube from you
deserve a drink
okay so part of it she cuts a whole
bunch fruit up yeah never makes a drink
so you know we're talking orange thing
because I believe I'm both like southern
he's southern right no TV no jacksgap we
got it yeah we don't yeah I would still
kind of spend my life with them a real
journey okay so for this last little bit
let me get my man on your channel was
you made me a react to two girls one cup
cake farts and glass in the ass so I
thought instead of us reacting to that
video we're gonna react to the videos in
that video
Oh feel like I'm just gonna be like yes
I know I won't find anything like silly
nothing's going to shock me anymore I
mean I've seen the rise of Donald Trump
what it can't be real how did she make
herself that gasps look at the eye of
soro I immediately such muscle memory of
feeling this exact way the first time
that we went through I thought I was
okay with it until she was pushing out
and it looks directly into my retina the
music
[Applause]
oh I could genuinely throw another two
girls one cup that was really that was
not okay and I felt like back then I was
very like this is fun and funny this is
not what I'm letting into my life okay
let's uh bring the energy back down with
some casual meatloaf ourselves just a
gassy bit it's in the same house I will
say this is this is a new spaghetti
strapp this is a different day that's
ketchup yeah she's on a beat oh I love
ketchup then Pepsi promo get that spawns
guys what's the narrative here or an
effect no I think most of it is no the
last one is the one that you introduced
me to the first time around that I had
no know what kids in the sandbox class
may ask
classic oh no at some point it's gonna
be long it's gonna go wrong and I
remember it it's jarring didn't love it
yeah you know the thing that I'm really
proud about is my consistent negativity
towards peace I feel like yes I feel
like five years ago I was very like look
at it like you know I'm with you but
thank you for taking
trip down memory lane I hated every
minute of it and also thank you guys for
watching we made a video over on Tyler's
channel but also something really fun is
that Tyler and Korey have relaunched
their podcast psychobabble that's
available every Tuesday and y'all have
relaunched will not relaunched wash yeah
mamrie and I have a podcast this make it
weird and it's every Wednesday and so
you guys should make sure your Tuesdays
and Wednesdays are set for those kinds
of fun shenanigans what I would like and
let me know if you guys would like this
give it this video thumbs up if you
think is a good idea um I would like to
do a hosts swap Oh wouldn't it be fun I
love that idea
kind of fun or do you I'm doing this
video uh okay great this sing it if you
would okay yeah I make sure you go to
Tyler's channel and check out the video
that we did over there we did a thank
you next about pop culture trends and
fun things yeah like comment subscribe
I don't know do whatever [ __ ] you what I
don't know I love that for them you see
that box fan the bed on the bed the guy
I was dating at the time needed the fan
like this far away from his face at all
times at night and he would sleep with
it facing him in like full blast on his
face and once we were so blackout drunk
and we woke up and he had puked into the
family it had literally blown back on to
both of us